the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi I'm herb gross and welcome to
calculus revisited I guess the most
difficult lecture to give in any course
is probably the first one and you're
sort of tempted to look at your audience
and say you're probably wondering why I
called you all here and in this sense I
have elected to entitle our first
lecture simply preface to give a double
overview an overview both of the
hardware and the software that will make
up this course to begin with we will
have a series of lectures of which this
is the first in our lectures our main
aim will be to give an overview of the
material being covered and insight as to
why various computations are done and
insights as to how applications of these
concepts will be made the part of our
course will consist of a regular
textbook you see we have our lectures we
have a textbook the textbook is designed
to supply you with deeper insights than
what we can give in a lecture in
addition recognizing the fact that the
textbook may leave gaps places where you
may want some additional knowledge we
also have supplementary notes and
finally at the backbone of our package
is what we call the study guide the
study guide consists of a breakdown of
the course it tells us what the various
lectures will be the units there are
pretest to help you decide how well
prepared you are for the topic that's
coming up there is a final examination
at the end of each block of material and
perhaps most importantly especially from
an engineer's point of view in each unit
that we study the study guide will
consist of exercises primarily called
learning exercises exercises which
hopefully will turn you on towards
wanting to be able to apply the material
at the same time serve as a springboard
by which we can highlight why the theory
and
many of our lecture points are really as
important as they are so much for the
hardware of our course and now let's
turn our attention to the software just
what is calculus in a manner of speaking
calculus can be viewed as being high
school mathematics with one additional
concept called the limit concept thrown
in if you recall back to your high
school days remember that we were always
dealing with things like average rate of
speed notice I say average our constant
rate of speed the old recipe that
distance equals rate times time
presupposes that the rate is constant
because if the rate is varying which
rate is it that you use to multiply the
time by to find the distance you see in
other words roughly speaking we can say
that at least one branch of calculus
known as differential calculus deals
with the subject of instantaneous speed
and instantaneous speed is a rather easy
thing to talk about intuitively imagine
an object moving along this line and
passing the point P and we say to
ourselves how fast was the object moving
at the instant that we were at the point
P now you see this is some sort of a
problem because at the instant that you
act P you're not in a sense moving it
out because you're at P of course what
we do to reduce this new problem to an
old one is we say well suppose we had a
couple of observers let's call them o 1
and O 2
let them be stations one on each side of
P now certainly what we can do
physically here is we can measure the
distance between o 1 and O 2 and we can
also measure the time that it takes to
go from o 1 2 O 2 and what we can do is
divide that distance by the time and
that you see is our old high school
concept of the average speed of the
particle as it moves from all one two oh
two now you see the question is somebody
says gee that's a great answer
the wrong problem we didn't ask what was
the average speed as we went from all
one - OH - we asked what was the
instantaneous speed and the idea is we
say well look at the average speed and
the instantaneous speed it seems should
be pretty much the same if the observers
were relatively close together the next
observation is it seems that if we were
to move the observers in even closer
there would be less of a discrepancy
between R 1 and O 2 in the sense that
not a discrepancy but in the sense that
the average speed would now seem like a
better approximation to the
instantaneous speed because there was
less distance for something to go wrong
in and so we get the idea that maybe
what we should do is make the observers
get closer and closer together that
would minimize the difference between
the average speed and the instantaneous
rate of speed and maybe the optimal
thing would happen when the two
observers were together but the strange
part is and this is where calculus
really begins this is what calculus is
all about as soon as the observers come
together
notice that what you have is that the
distance between them is zero the time
that it takes to get from one to the
other is zero and therefore it appears
that if we divide distance by time we
are going to wind up with zero over zero
now my claim is that zero over zero
should be called well I'll call it
undefined but actually I think
indeterminate
indeterminate would be a better word why
do I say that well here's an interesting
thing when we do arithmetic with small
numbers observe that if you add two
small numbers you expect the result to
be a small number if you multiply two
small numbers you expect the result to
be a small number
similarly for division for subtraction
the difference of two small numbers is a
small number on the other hand the
quotient of two small numbers is rather
deceptive because it's a ratio if one of
the very small numbers happens to be
very much larger compared with the other
small number the ratio might be quite
large
well for example visualize say 10 to the
minus 6 1 1 million you see point 0 0 0
0 0 1 which is a pretty small number now
divide that by 10 to the minus 12 where
you see 10 to the minus 12th is a small
number so smaller that makes 10 to the
minus sixth appear large in fact the
quotient is 10 to the 6th which is a
million and here we see that when you're
dealing with the ratio of small numbers
you're a little bit of trouble because
we can't tell whether the ratio will be
small or large or is somewhere in
between for example if we reverse the
role of numerator and denominator here
we would still have the quotient of two
small numbers but 10 to the minus
twelfth divided by 10 to the minus 6
is a relatively small number ten to the
minus six of course this is the physical
way of looking at it small / small as in
determinant we have a more rigorous way
of looking at this if you want to see it
from a mathematical structure point of
view namely suppose we define a / b in
the traditional way namely a / b is that
number such that when we multiply it by
B we get a well what would that say as
far as 0 / 0 was concerned it would say
what that 0 / 0 is that number such that
when we multiply it by 0 we get 0 now
what number has the property that when
we multiply it by 0 we get 0 and the
answer is any number this is y 0 over 0
is indeterminate if we say to a person
tell me the number I must multiply by 0
to get 0 the answer is any number well
the idea that is that we must avoid the
expression 0 / 0 at all costs what this
means then is that we say ok let the
observers get closer and closer together
but never touch now the point is that as
long as the observers get closer and
closer together and never touch let's
ask the question how many pairs of
observers do we need and the answer is
that theoretically we need infinitely
many pairs of observers well why is that
because as long as there's a distance
between a pair of observers we can
theoretically fit in another pair of
observers this is why in our course we
do not begin with this idea but looking
backwards now we say ah we had better
find some way of giving us the
equivalent of having instantly many
pairs of observers and to do this
the idea that we come up with is the
concept called a function consider the
old Galileo freely falling body problem
with a distance that the body Falls s
equals 16 T squared where T is in
seconds and SS and feet notice that this
apparently harmless recipe gives us a
way for finding s for each given T in
other words to all intents and purposes
this recipe gives us an observer for
each point of time see for each time we
can find the distance which is
physically equivalent to knowing an
observer at every point in turn the
study of functions lends itself to a
study of graphs a picture namely if we
look at s equals 16 T squared again
notice that we visualize a recipe here T
can be viewed as being an input s is the
output for a given input T we can
compute the output s in general if we
now elect to plot the input along a
horizontal line and the output at right
angles to this we now have a picture of
our relationship a picture which is
called a graph you see let we can talk
about this more explicitly as far as
this particular problem is concerned
just by taking a look at a picture like
this in other words in this particular
problem the input is time T the output
is distance s for each T we locate a
height called s by squaring T and
multiplying by 16 and now what average
speed means in terms of this kind of a
diagram is the following to find the
average speed all we have to do is on a
given time interval find the distance
traveled which I call Delta s the change
in distance and divide that by the
change in time that's the average speed
which by the way from a geometrical
point of view becomes known as the slope
of this particular straight line in
other words average speed is two
functions
what slope of a straight line is to a
geometry at any rate knowing what the
average rate of speed is we sort of say
why couldn't we define the instantaneous
speed to be this we will take the change
in distance divided by the change in
time and see what happens and we write
this this way limit as delta T
approaches zero let's see what happens
as that change in time becomes
arbitrarily small but never equaling
zero because we don't want a zero over
zero form here you see this then becomes
the working definition of something of
what we call differential calculus the
point is that this particular definition
does not depend on s equalling 16t
squared s could be any function of t
whatsoever we could have a more
elaborate type of situation the
important point is what the basic
definition stays the same
what changes is the amount of arithmetic
that's necessary to handle the
particular relationship between s and T
this will be a major part of our course
the strange thing being that even at the
very end of our course when we've gone
through many many things our basic
definition of the instantaneous rate of
change will have never changed from this
it will always stay like this but what
will change is how much arithmetic and
algebra and geometry and trigonometry
etc we will have to do in order to
compute these things from a numerical
point of view well so much for the first
phase of calculus called differential
calculus a second phase of calculus one
which was developed by the ancient
Greeks by 600 BC the subject that
ultimately becomes known as integral
calculus concerns the problem of finding
area under a curve here I've elected to
draw the hyperbola the parabola y equals
x squared on the interval from 0 0 to 1
0 and the question basically is what is
the area
bounded by this sort of triangular
region let's call that region R and what
we would like to find is the area of the
region R and the ancient Greeks had a
rather interesting title for this type
of approach for finding the area it is
both figurative and literal I guess it's
called the method of exhaustion what
they did was to is they would divide the
interval say into n equal parts and
picking the lowest point in each
interval they would inscribe a rectangle
they would knowing that the area of the
rectangle was the base times the height
they would add up the area of each of
these rectangles and know that whatever
that area was that would have to be too
small to be the right answer because
that region was contained in R and that
would be labeled a sub n lower bar say
to indicate that this was a sum of
rectangles which was too small to be the
right answer
similarly they would then find the
highest point in each rectangle get an
over approximation by adding up the sum
of those areas which they would call a
sub n upper bar and now know that the
area of the region's they were looking
for was squeezed in between these two
then what they would do is make more and
more divisions and hopefully and I think
you can see this sort of intuitively
happening here each of the lower
approximations gets bigger and fills out
the space from inside each of the upper
approximations get smaller and chops off
the space from outside here and
hopefully if both of these bounds sort
of converge to the same value L we get
the idea that the area of the region R
must be L this is not anything new in
other words this is a technique that is
some 2,500 years old used by the ancient
Greeks of course what happens with
engineering students in general is that
one frequently says but I'm not
interested in studying area I am NOT a
geometer I am a physicist I am an
engineer
what good is the area under a curve and
the interesting point here becomes that
if we label the coordinate axes rather
than x and y give them physical labels
it turns out that area under a curve has
a physical interpretation because there
is the same problem only now instead of
talking about y equals x squared let's
talk about V the velocity equaling the
square of the time and say that the time
goes from 0 to 1 in other words if we
plot V versus T we get a picture like
this and the question that comes up is
what do we mean by the area under the
curve here and again without belaboring
this point not because it's not
important but because this is just an
overview when we will come back to all
of these topics later in our course the
point I just want to bring out here is
notice that the area under the curve
here is the distance that this particle
would travel moving at this speed if the
time goes from 0 to 1 and notice what
we're saying here again suppose we
divide this interval into n equal parts
and inscribe rectangles
notice that this that each of these
rectangles represents a distance namely
if a particle moved at this speed
at this speed see over this length of
time the area under the curve would be
the distance that had traveled during
that time interval in other words what
we're saying is that if the particle
moved at this speed from this time to
this time then moved at this speed from
this time to this time the sum of these
two areas would give the distance that
the particle traveled which obviously is
less than the distance that the particle
truly traveled because notice that the
particle was moving at a speed which at
every instant from hitted here was
greater than this and every instant from
here to here was greater than this in
other words in the same way as before
that the area of the region arc was
whittled in between a sub n upper bar
and a sub n lower bar notice that the
distance travelled by the particle can
now be limited or bounded in the same
way and the same way that we found area
as a limit we can now find distance as a
limit and these two things namely what
instantaneous speed an area under a
curve are the two essential branches of
calculus differential calculus being
concerned with instantaneous rate of
speed integral calculus with area under
a curve and the beauty of calculus
surprisingly enough in a way is only
secondary as far as these two topics are
concerned the true beauty lies in the
fact that these apparently two different
branches of calculus one of which was
invented by the ancient Greek as early
as 600 BC the other of which
differential calculus was not known to
man until the time of Isaac Newton in 60
ad are related by a rather remarkable
thing that remarkable thing which we
will emphasize that great length during
our course is that areas and rates of
change are related by area under a curve
now I don't know how to draw this which
you can see this thing as vividly as
possible but the idea is this think of
area being swept out as we take a line
and
move it tracing out the curve this way
towards the right notice that if we have
a certain amount of area if we have a
certain amount of area if we now move a
little bit further to the right notice
that the new area the new area somehow
depends on what the height of this curve
is going to be that somehow or other it
seems that the area under the curve must
be related to how fast the height of
this line is changing or to look at it
inversely how fast the area is changing
should somehow be related to the height
of this line and just what that
relationship is will be explored also in
great detail in the course and we will
show the beautiful marriage between this
differential and integral calculus
through this relationship here which
becomes known as the fundamental theorem
of integral calculus at any rate then
what this should show us is that
calculus hinges whether it's
differential calculus or integral
calculus that calculus hinges on
something called the limit concept again
by way of a very quick review one of the
limit concepts and I think it's easy to
see geometrically rather than
analytically imagine that we have a
curve and we want to find the tangent to
the curve at the point P what we can do
is is take a point Q and draw the
straight line that joins P to Q we can
then find the slope of the line PQ the
trouble is that PQ does not look very
much like the tangent line so we say
okay let Q move down so it comes closer
to P we can then find the slopes of PQ 1
we can find the slope of PQ 2 but in
each case we still do not have the slope
of the line tangent to the curve at P
but we get the idea that as Q gets
closer and closer to P the slope of the
secant line that joins P to Q becomes a
better and better approximation to the
line that would be tangent to the curve
P in fact it's rather interesting that
in the 16th century the definition that
was given of a tangent line was that a
tangent line is a line which passes
through two consecutive points on a
curve now obviously a curve does not
have two consecutive points what they
really meant was what that as Q gets
closer and closer to P the secant line
becomes a better and better
approximation for the tangent line and
that in a way if the two points were
allowed to coincide that should give us
the perfect answer the trouble is just
like you can divide 0 by 0 if P and Q
coincide how many points do you have
just one point and it takes two points
to determine a straight line no matter
how close Q is to P we have two distinct
points as soon as Q touches p we lose
this and this is what was meant by
ancient man a medieval man by his notion
of two consecutive points and I should
put this in double quotes because I
think you can see what he's begging to
try to say with the word consecutive
even though from a purely rigorous point
of view this has no geometric meaning
now the other form of limit has to do
with adding up areas of rectangles under
curves namely we divide the curve up
into n parts we inscribed n rectangles
and then we let n increase without bound
in other words this is sort of a
discrete type of limit namely we must
add up a whole number of areas but the
sum is endless in the sense that the
number of rectangles becomes greater
than any number we want to pre-assign
and the basic question that we must
contend with here the basic question
that we must contend with here is how
big is an infinite sum you see when we
say infinite sum that just tells you how
many terms you're combining it doesn't
tell you how big each term how big the
sum will be for example look at the
following some I will start with one
then I'll add a half arm twice then I'll
add a third on three times and without
belaboring these at this point let me
then say I'll add on
for four times 1/5 5 times 1/6 6 times
etc notice as I do this that each time
the terms get smaller yet the sum
increases without any bound namely
notice that this adds up to 1 this adds
up to 1 the next four terms will add up
to 1 and as I go out further and further
notice that this sum can become as great
as I want just by me adding on enough 1
on the other hand let's look at this one
1 plus 1/2 plus 1/4 plus 1/8 plus 1/16
plus 1/32 in other words I start with 1
and each time add on half the previous
number C 1 plus 1/2 plus 1/4 plus 1/8
you may remember this as being the
geometric series
EKU's ratio is 1/2 the interesting thing
is that now this sum gets as close to 2
as you want without ever getting there
and rather than prove this right now
let's just look at the geometric
interpretation here take a line which is
2 inches long suppose you first go half
way you're now here now go half the
remaining distance that's what 1 plus
1/2 that put you over here now go half
the remaining distance that means add on
1/4 now go half the remaining distance
that means add on 1/8 now go half the
remaining distance add up as on the 16th
you see and ultimately what happens well
no matter where you stop
you've become closer and closer to 2
without ever getting there and as you go
further and further you can get as close
to 2 as you want in other words here are
infinitely many terms whose infinite sum
is 2 here are infinitely many terms
whose infinite sum is infinity we should
say because it increases without bound
and this was the problem that hung up
the ancient Greek how could you do
instantly many things in a finite amount
of time in fact at the same time of the
Greek was developing integral calculus
the famous Greek philosopher Zeno
was working on things called Zeno's
paradoxes and Zeno's paradoxes are three
a number of which I only want to quote
one here but it's a paradox which shows
how Zeno could not visualize quite what
was happening you see it's called The
Tortoise and the hare problem suppose
that you give the tortoise a 1-yard head
start on the hare and suppose for the
sake of argument just to mimic the
problem that we were doing before
suppose it's a slow here and a fast
tortoise so the hare only runs twice as
fast as the tortoise you see Zeno's
paradox says that the hare can never
catch the tortoise why because that's to
catch the Tortoise the hare must first
go the 1-yard head start that the
tortoise had well by the time the hair
gets here the tortoise has gone a half
yard because the toilets travels half as
fast now that here must make up the half
yard
but while the hare makes up the half
yard the tortoise goes a quarter of the
yard when the hare makes up the quarter
of the odd the tortoise goes 1/8 of the
yard and so see now I'd use the hair
gets closer and closer to the tortoise
but can't catch up and this of course is
a rather strange thing because Zeno knew
that the tortoise would catch the hair
that's why it's called a paradox a
paradox means something which appears to
be true yet is obviously false now
notice that we can resolve Zeno's
paradox into the example we were just
talking about for the sake of argument
notice what's happening here with the
time for the sake of argument let's
suppose that the tortoise travels at one
yard per second then what you're saying
is I mean the hare travels at one yard
per second what you're saying is it
takes two here one second to go this
distance then it takes them a half a
second to go this distance then a
quarter of a second to go this distance
and what you're saying is is that as
he's gaining on the tortoise these are
the time intervals which are transpiring
and this sum turns out to be 2 now of
course those of us who had 8th grade
algebra know an easier way of solving
this problem we say look at let's solve
this problem algebraically namely we say
give
The Tortoise a 1-yard head start now
call X the distance R the point at which
the hare catches the tortoise now the
hare is traveling one yard per second
the tortoise is traveling a half a yard
per second okay
so if we take distance the distance
traveled and divided by the rate that
should take the time that should be the
time and since they both are at this
point at the same time we get one x over
1 equals X minus 1 divided by 1/2 and
assuming as a prerequisite that we have
had algebra it follows almost trivially
that x equals 2 in other words what this
says is in reality that the hare will
not overtake the tortoise until he
catches them which is obvious but what's
not so obvious is what that these
infinitely many terms can add up to a
finite sum well any rate this completes
the overview of what our course will be
like and to help you focus your
attention on what our course really says
what we shall do computationally is this
in review we shall start with functions
and functions involve the modern concept
of sets because they're relationships
between sets of objects we will talk
about limits derivatives rate of change
integrals area under curves this will be
our fundamental building block once this
is done these things will never change
but the remainder of our course will be
to talk about applications which is the
name of the game as far as engineering
is concerned more elaborate functions
namely how do we handle tougher
relationships related to the tougher
relationships will come more
sophisticated techniques and finally we
will conclude our course with the topic
that we were just talking about infinite
series how do we get a hold of what
happens when you add up instantly many
things each of which gets small at any
rate that concludes our lecture
for today we will have a digression in
the sense that the next few lessons will
consist of sets things that you can read
about that Julie sure in our
supplementary notes learn to understand
these because the concept of a set is
the building block the fundamental
language of modern mathematics and then
we will return once we have sets
underway to talk about functions and
then we will build gradually from there
hopefully when our course ends we will
have in slow motion gone through today's
lesson this completes our presentation
for today and until next time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate